[Musique]
vous diriez que Tucked pourtant a été l'une des
communautés les plus touchées par le
changement climatique dans tout le Canada, c'est en
face qu'on nous dit que la
communauté de Tuck elle-même n'existera plus d'ici 50 à 80
ans.
pourrait se heurter à un désastre
où la communauté se trouve là où se trouve l'
hôpital dans un certain nombre de maisons sera
perdu dans la mer il disparaîtra
si vous vivez avec une transformation perpétuelle
alors ce qui se passe avec le
changement climatique n'est pas si radicalement différent
encore une fois, ce ne sont que des souvenirs
que nous  non, je ne vois plus ça,
nous voulons rester ici, je ne vivrais jamais
ailleurs
[Musique]